Vsauce! Kevin here. We’re in an era where
crime scene investigators, lab techs,
and detectives seem almost superhuman
— some of the best shows on TV blend
forensics and data to analyze criminal
behavior to a remarkable degree. You’d
think everyone is Sherlock Holmes. And
it is true that our use of science and
math to solve crimes — and to understand the
people who commit them — is advancing rapidly.
But Jennifer Thompson’s eyewitness
identification of her attacker was
flat-out wrong — and a broken police lineup
methodology encouraged an error that put Ronald
Cotton in prison for a decade. Both a judge
and jury misunderstanding simple probability
convicted Janet Collins for an assault
and robbery she had nothing to do with.
The truth is that as we advance, we run
into serious problems, new limitations,
and unintended consequences. I’ve
spent a year studying stories that
reveal the delicate balance of
scientific progress and justice.
These seven videos have been compiled
into one longform viewing session for
your convenience and I’ll be back at
the end to discuss what we’ve learned.
First, imagine the FBI arresting you for
an act of terrorism that happened over
5,000 miles away -- and insisting
that international authorities have
somehow forensically tied you to a bomb on
another continent. You went to bed innocent.
But because of faulty fingerprint
analysis, you woke up a terrorist.
Vsauce, Kevin here. Imagine the horror of being
arrested in connection to a crime
the entire world is reading about,
on the basis of irrefutable fingerprint
evidence, that you KNOW you didn’t commit.
How do you defend yourself against a
century of science and math that just…
aren’t wrong? And how can you possibly
win when you’re up against the FBI,
and your own fingerprint expert
says your fingerprints are a match?
The first arrest of an American in connection
with the Madrid train bombings… what led
the FBI to Portland, Oregon? Supporters of
the man say agents are on the wrong track.
In Spain, they call it 11M. On March 11, 2004,
just 3 days before Spain’s general elections,
explosions ripped through trains in Madrid.
193 people were killed and about 2,000 were
injured. Europe hadn’t experienced
an attack on that scale in decades,
and it came in the wake of 9/11 and at
the peak of the global war on terror.
Fingerprints were found on a bag that contained
detonating devices, and Spanish authorities
put them into the Interpol database. The
FBI in the United States found a match to
Latent Fingerprint 17, and in May, Brandon
Mayfield, a U.S. Army veteran and family law
attorney who frequently worked with low-income
clients in Portland, Oregon, took the blame.
How does a lawyer 5,403 miles away
from a crime become its prime suspect?
To understand what went wrong here, we
need to go all the way back to Darwin.
Throughout the 1800’s, scientists advanced the
notion that a pattern of epidermal ridges on
human fingertips, toes, and palms were unique
to each human, and they could be used as a proof
of one’s identity -- like a built-in biological
signature. Scottish surgeon Henry Faulds proposed
that they could be cataloged and recorded
with ink, and he asked Charles Darwin for
help. Darwin was a bit too old to undertake a
real analysis, so he passed it onto his cousin
Francis Galton -- whose many accomplishments
included identifying the statistical regression
to the mean and inventing a physical board to
demonstrate it that we now see on game shows.
The science around fingerprint identification
flourished, and by the beginning of the 20th
century, it had become one of the best ways
to pinpoint criminals -- and especially repeat
offenders. It replaced systems like branding
skin, which France outlawed in 1832. It was
much more scientific than Alphonse
Bertillon’s anthropometric forensics,
a measurement of physical factors including head
length, head breadth, length of middle finger,
length of the left foot, eye color and
hair color -- by assigning values for each,
Bertillon claimed each person would have
a unique combination of data. Except… it
wasn’t all that unique, since so many physical
attributes correlate with one another. Like,
most tall people also have long arms, you don’t
find many 5 foot 3 men with 7-foot wingspans.
Fingerprints were much more accurate,
and Bertllon developed a system of 16
identifiable markers that remained standard
for over a century. Starting in 1924,
the US government began compiling and
cataloging fingerprints, and by 2004,
they had about 200 million on file. A wavelet
scalar quantization algorithm was employed to
compress the 500 pixel-per-inch images down
to a file size of just 500kb -- which meant
easier storage, quicker access, and smoother
online transfers globally. Like to Spain.
And by that time, it had been a century since
Francis Galton’s forgotten warning that,
“A complex pattern [like fingerprints] is capable
of suggesting various readings, as the figuring on
a wallpaper may suggest a variety of forms
and faces to those who have such fancies.”
Even though the prints sent
from Spain were low quality,
an FBI examiner signed an affidavit stating that,
“the FBI lab stands by their conclusion
of a 100 percent positive identification.”
In the weeks leading up to his arrest,
Brandon felt like he was being watched…
because he was literally being watched. FBI
documents show that as soon as Brandon’s
fingerprints popped as a potential match, he
was immediately under 24-hour FBI surveillance,
including phone and digital monitoring. He also
suspected break-ins at his home and his office,
because… they were both really broken into.
They were convinced Mayfied was involved.
Here’s a question! If fingerprints
are so foolproof, why was an innocent
man harassed by the government and
detained for weeks as he wondered
why they thought he was connected
to a crime on another continent?
Spanish authorities actually knew Mayfield’s print
wasn’t a match -- before the FBI detained him.
They communicated a result of “Negativo” after
their own fingerprint experts found too few points
matching in the prints. So what’d the FBI do? The
FBI flew to Madrid and told them they were wrong.
As they investigated Mayfield, they found that
he’d converted to Islam. They also noted that
a year prior to 11M, he’d represented a man
accused of involvement in a terror plot in
Oregon. The more they looked into his life,
the more circumstantial evidence they found
that suggested Mayfield had the means and
motive to play a role in the attack -- and
that’s actually the punchline to a
joke about a lying Texas sharpshooter.
The joke’s about a man who shoots at the side of
a barn, and then draws a target around a cluster
of bullet holes to suggest that he’s actually a
great shooter. When that’s done with data, it’s
called the “multiple comparisons problem.” When
we falsely perceive connections in our heads, it’s
“apophenia.” And when you’re fitting evidence to
a predetermined conclusion, that has a name too.
Psychologist Peter Wason coined the
term “confirmation bias” to describe
one’s tendency to focus on evidence that
supports their beliefs and to ignore or
reject evidence that contradicts it. Basically,
it’s cherry-picking the truth, and it almost
guarantees that you’ll find exactly what you’re
looking for -- even if that isn’t reality.
SO WHAT WAS THE REALITY?
An FBI report
years after the incident admitted
that Mayfield was actually one of
20 potential matches to the LF-17
fingerprint. Once they looked into
Mayfield’s life and found details
that supported their suspicions,
he became the prime suspect. Because he served
in the military, he probably had the knowledge
to be involved. His tangential past connections
to suspected terrorists were further proof. And
since he’d converted to Islam, he checked
almost every box on the FBI’s profile list.
And remember Mayfield’s house being searched?
Evidence was seized from his residence,
including what the FBI called “Spanish documents.”
They turned out to be his son’s Spanish homework.
Okay, okay, okay. But why did Mayfield’s own
defense experts agree with the FBI that his
prints were a match? They both claimed there was
an “unusual similarity” between the two prints,
with the Office of the Inspector General
noting that they considered the coincidence
to be “extraordinarily rare.” And now we’re
back to people being accused of crimes based
on hypothetical low probability -- just like
Sally Clark’s tragic case in my last video.
The FBI deliberately manipulated their
conclusions by ignoring that the LF-17
print was only a slight match with
Mayfield’s -- and then they focused
on evidence that supported Mayfield’s
guilt and ignored the parts that didn’t.
But the FBI’s bad judgment was also a
function of a weird problem we have when
we get better at collecting and using data.
Think of crime in Galton’s era -- there was
essentially no real information to work from.
It was very difficult to verify a suspect’s
identity. It was hard to find a suspect
given that there was no video evidence,
hardly any photography, and primitive
forensics at best. It would be generations
before we could begin to collect and
process things like blood types and DNA.
The FBI didn’t have too little
data. They actually had too much.
They knew every little detail
about Brandon Mayfield’s life,
from his browser history to what was in his
garbage. The sheer volume of information made
it easy for them to find exactly what they were
looking for and only what they were looking for.
Here’s an example of how that data and knowledge
gap quickly goes wrong. Swedish power lines.
In 1992, Swedish researchers concluded a
25-year longitudinal study to determine
whether living near high-voltage power lines
made people sick. They studied the rates of
over 800 different illnesses and found that
childhood leukemia was 4 times more common
near power lines. Their data wasn’t wrong. The
problem was... by measuring so many variables,
they basically guaranteed that at
least ONE of them would be a weird
statistical outlier -- and then they used it
as proof of a cause-and-effect relationship.
You can actually visualize what this is
like. Look. If I have a bag of dice and
dump them all on my table, what’s gonna happen?
Most of them will form a scattered pile right
under where I dump them. But you KNOW that
1 or 2 of em are gonna fly off my table,
bounce on the carpet, and lodge themselves
under a filing cabinet 10 feet away.
Why?!? They’re outliers, it just
happens. Alright, back to Mayfield.
The FBI had a preconceived notion of who was
likely to have been involved in 11M. They
had seemingly-reliable forensic evidence
to support a suspect’s identification.
They had so much information about that
suspect, all so easily available digitally,
that they could find information that perfectly
fit their profile. They dismissed the high volume
of exculpatory data… like whether Brandon
Mayfield was even in Europe before M-11. HE
WASN’T. His passport had expired years ago
-- but the FBI claimed that meant Mayfield
must’ve traveled under another identity.
For them, the absence of proof was proof.
Mayfield was detained for 2 weeks as a “material
witness” -- NOT arrested as an actual suspect,
since holding him as a material witness
required far less evidence. The FBI
kept collecting information they thought
proved Mayfield’s guilt -- but everything
came crashing down when Spanish authorities
announced that they’d found the person who
was actually involved in 11M. They matched the
LF-17 print to those of an Algerian terrorist,
and they were right. The FBI’s experts
agreed that these prints were truly a match.
Mayfield was released immediately --
and then the questions began. As the
American Civil Liberties Union and other civil
rights advocates excoriated the FBI for having
wrongly profiled him, the FBI analyzed what
went wrong internally. They laid part of the
blame on what they saw as the poor quality
of the original digital image of LF-17,
but a panel of international fingerprint
experts suggested that the FBI had far
too much confidence in the Integrated Automated
Fingerprint Identification System, which is the
largest biometric database in the world, and let
the pressure of a high profile case determine how
they viewed the evidence -- and what evidence they
collected at all. The panel also concluded that,
“FBI culture discouraged fingerprint examiners
from disagreeing with their superiors.”
The Department of Justice released a 330-page
report that admitted to analytical and procedural
errors, and academic journals churned out articles
analyzing the validity of fingerprint analysis,
the rate of false positives, and fingerprinting’s
role in criminal trials. Regarding the validity of
fingerprinting, a science historian at UC-Irvine
said, “How do you explain to the court that what
you’ve been saying for 100 years was exaggerated,
but you still have something meaningful to say?”
Mayfield’s case led to lawsuits about potential
misuse and constitutionality of the Patriot Act,
a $2 million judgment in his favor,
and a formal apology from the US
Government. Mayfield went back to practicing law.
Nearly two decades after Mayfield’s
unconscionable injustice, we have even
more data and information about everything
-- and about everyone. It’s amazing how much
we can know and how quickly we can know it.
Everything from medical records to finding
a gem mint Charizard is way faster than
it used to be, and usually more accurate.
That’s generally a good thing. But… sometimes
all that information is a problem. Even when
it’s perfectly accurate, the way we use it
might not be. We can make good data bad,
and it’s getting even more
difficult to get it right.
Mayfield’s case highlights the complex
relationship between the objectivity of
science and math and the fallibility
of the human mind. As we advance,
we find more ways to be right -- and
that also means more ways to be wrong.
The not-quite-100% reliability of fingerprint
analysis may have initially failed Brandon
Mayfield, but the unchecked flaws of the
human mind are what landed him in a jail cell.
Sometimes the math and science are right,
and the way we use them, the way
people use what’s right... is wrong.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Vsauce! Kevin here, with a serial killer
who may very well have murdered hundreds.
Her systematic killing spree went
undetected for years because suspicion
just wasn’t enough. What finally
brought her to justice was… math.
In the United States, the most dangerous
place you can go is… the hospital. Yes,
doctors and nurses save lives literally
every single day, but medical error is a
significant cause of death. No matter how hard
we try, tragedies happen -- and by definition,
everyone in a hospital is already sick with
something. But murder isn’t an accident,
and a nurse in Massachusetts was straight-up
killing patients… to impress a guy.
Kristen Gilbert was a nurse at the Veterans
Administration Medical Center in Northampton,
Massachusetts. She was popular with co-workers.
She’d go out clubbing with them in Boston to blow
off steam, and even threw baby showers. She also
seemed to be really good at her job -- it felt
like she was always around to save the day in an
emergency. She appeared to be the perfect nurse.
But Gilbert was around so often
when patients died that other
nurses jokingly referred to
her as the “Angel of Death.”
It seemed like the Northampton hospital
had a lot of unexpected deaths… but a VA
investigation found that the hospital’s rate of
deaths was in line with similar VA hospitals.
So. Case closed, right? WRONG.
Doctors and nurses weren’t convinced, but
there were no witnesses who saw Gilbert
actually do anything suspicious to patients.
There wasn’t any evidence. But there was data.
Here’s a question: how often did patients
die when Gilbert was on the floor,
compared to when she wasn’t? Was there a
correlation between her presence and patient
deaths? And if so… was it just an unlucky
coincidence? Or was she killing people?
The first analysis can be expressed
visually -- this graph shows patient
deaths in the hospital ward between 1988 and
1997 broken down into 3 shifts: day, evening,
and overnight. The 4pm - midnight evening
shift stands out as having the most deaths,
and Kristen Gilbert worked the evening shift.
But that doesn’t hold for every year. 1988 and
1989 don’t match up with the 6 years that follow
it. There weren’t that many deaths, and they were
pretty evenly distributed throughout the day.
Kristen Gilbert didn’t start
working on the ward until 1990.
Okay. Okay. What about the really high number of
deaths during overnight shifts in 1990? That’s
an outlier in this whole data set -- Gilbert
worked evenings, but when she started in 1990,
she worked the overnight shift.
HUH.
HUH. HUH.
But this graph is still not proof.
Variation in human outcomes is tremendous,
whether it’s education or physical
fitness or death. It’s totally
possible that Kristen Gilbert was present
during a statistical blip. It’s possible
there’s some nurse out there working on
a floor where patients never seem to die,
like some kind of Angel of Life! Just ask Brandon
Mayfield whether coincidences happen. Or the FBI.
Dr. Stephen Gehlbach, who is now Dean Emeritus
of UMass-Amherst’s School of Public Health,
ran the numbers. He looked at 1,641 nursing
shifts over the period of 18 months leading
up to staff taking their concerns to hospital
management. There were 74 deaths during those
shifts -- which is a death on 4.51% of
all shifts, or .045 deaths per shift.
Kristen Gilbert worked 257 shifts during that
18 month period. With .045 deaths per shift,
we’d expect her to be present for about 11 or
12 deaths -- about 1 every 6 weeks on average.
15 or 16 deaths when you expect 11 or 12 could
be an unlucky statistical anomaly. She was there
for 40. FORTY! A patient died on over 15% of
Gilbert’s shifts. What are the chances of THAT?
Literally 1 in 100 million -- and maybe even LESS.
In the handwriting analysis I
did of Sylvia Howland’s will,
Hetty Green’s forgery matched on way too many
points to chalk it up to a crazy coincidence,
1 in sextillions. Gehlbach calculated
p-values to estimate the chance of
Gilbert’s nursing death-rate at less than 1
in 100 million… but we know from the Sally
Clark trial that a probability like 1 in 73
million isn’t necessarily what it feels like
it is. Correlation isn’t causation. Maybe
her patients were just sicker than normal.
This time, that uncertainty was okay -- it
was enough for the grand jury to proceed.
A grand jury doesn’t have to determine guilt or
innocence the way a trial does. They just decide
whether the evidence is compelling enough
to proceed with criminal charges. They did.
Again. There wasn’t proof. But the math
gave enough context to the suspicions of
the Veterans Administration, hospital
management, and Gilbert’s co-workers
to proceed with charges -- but how was
she killing these people? And WHY?!?
Prosecutors alleged that Gilbert had injected
patients with epinephrine – which you probably
know as adrenaline, which sped up their hearts and
caused cardiac failure. Adrenaline is untraceable,
but the hospital found that it had a
lot of epinephrine go missing during
Gilbert’s employment. And some of
the patients -- like Henry Hudon,
who was relatively young and a
paranoid-schizophrenia patient,
weren’t likely to have 3 heart attacks in one
night without something artificially causing it.
But… why would a professional mother of 2
in suburbia become a deranged super-villain?
Well… She seemed to have delusions of grandeur
in which she herself put patients in critical
condition and then heroically tried to resuscitate
them. She had a history of manipulative behavior,
mental illness, and abuse of patients
-- as a home care aide in the 1980s,
she scalded a mentally disabled
child with hot bath water on purpose.
Kristen Gilbert may have been unhinged -- but
she was also in love. Obsessively in love.
Every time a patient coded, hospital policy
mandated that a police officer engage in CPR.
In late 1995 and early 1996, the same police
officer responded to every single cardiac arrest
that Gilbert reported: James Perrault, Kristen’s
boyfriend. The man she left her husband and two
children for. Witnesses noticed her touching
Perrault affectionately during resuscitation
efforts and wiping his sweaty brow. Court
papers show that "One witness will testify
that he observed Gilbert playing `footsie' with
Perrault during the middle of a code.” Gross.
Perrault ended the relationship, and
Gilbert was angry. On a phone call from
a psychiatric facility, she confessed to
him by saying, "You know I did it. I did
it. You wanted to know. I killed those guys."
Perrault immediately went to the authorities,
so… she called in a bomb threat to
the VA hospital where they worked.
Decades of troubling behavior culminated in a
systematic killing spree that allowed Gilbert
to be the focal point of crisis after crisis.
Staff testified about her access to the adrenaline
that induced cardiac events, and doctors
testified that the unexpected excess deaths
were often relatively healthy, middle-aged
men. The same pattern just kept happening.
Kristen Gilbert was convicted of 4 murders and
2 attempted murders -- and the bomb threat to
a federal facility. It’s possible -- and
probable -- that she was involved in many,
many more patient deaths that weren’t the
accidents they seemed to be, but prosecutors
couldn’t prove it. She could’ve faced the
death penalty, but a compassionate judge and
jury sentenced her to a life in prison without
the possibility of parole -- plus 20 years.
The mathematical analysis that was so
critical to Gilbert’s downfall wasn’t
even used at the trial. The trial judge ruled
that the statistical evidence was prejudicial,
as it likely wouldn’t be understood by the jury as
NOT being iron-clad numerical proof of her guilt.
I’ve shown that math can be an incredible asset
in court… or that it can turn innocent people
into criminals. We’re getting used to scientific
and mathematical evidence, like DNA and forensics,
determining guilt or innocence -- but the reality
is math and science don’t have to do all the work.
Dozens, and maybe hundreds, of veterans
are alive in Massachusetts because of a
bar graph. Math and science don’t
always have to put out the fire.
Sometimes all they should do — and all
they need to do — is sound the alarm.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Vsauce! Kevin here -- Jennifer Thompson
studied every detail of her attacker's
face as she was being sexually assaulted at
knifepoint. His hairline, broad cheekbones,
a mustache that looked like a pencil-thin dirt
smear. She couldn't fight back physically,
but MENTALLY she could memorize every
little detail and bring him to justice.
Police described Jennifer as the best
witness they'd ever had. Her eyewitness
testimony convicted Ronald Cotton,
and he was sentenced to life in prison
plus 50 years despite no physical
evidence linking him to the crime.
There was no evidence because he
didn't do it -- and 11 years later,
DNA testing proved it. So how could the "best
witness ever" get it completely wrong? Why do
about 70% of DNA exonerations in the US
involve eyewitness misidentification?
And how can what we've seen turn
into something we never saw?
[intro]
I need you to… point to the shape that rolled
over your foot on the evening of March 14th, 2015.
Okay, this example seems stupid,
but it shows one of the many,
many problems with witness identification.
Only one shape in the lineup comes close
to the description of the suspect, the
choice is obvious. Only a circle can roll!
Now this lineup requires an actual
identification of size and color.
But here’s a question. How do you even get
to a lineup? First, you need a description.
Jennifer Thompson studied pages of ears,
chins, and noses so police could reconstruct
her attacker's face using an IdentiKit. In
1984, that was a sketch on paper -- now the
IdentiKit is digital. The hand-drawn facial
composite looked nearly perfect to her. Now
the police had a picture of the suspect
that could be broadcast on the local news.
Here’s the problem.
Some witnesses are amazing -- their
autobiographical memory of an event
is flawless. But then there’s the rest of
us, and Hugo Münsterberg wrote the book on
how what we forget and what we don’t know
becomes an illusion that replaces reality.
In 1908, Münsterberg published “On the Witness
Stand,” a collection of articles and essays
about psychological factors that affect trial
outcomes. What’s more persuasive than a witness
pointing to a defendant and swearing they did
it? Münsterberg insisted THAT gold standard
of evidence in a trial was actually… really
untrustworthy. Trials pre-date the ancient Greeks,
and while we’ve always known witnesses
could lie, only recently do we understand
how easy it is to THINK you’re telling
the truth when your brain is just… wrong.
Münsterberg suggested that justice often
miscarried due to the “treachery of human
memory” -- and to prove it, he pointed the
finger at himself. He wasn’t just some academic
pontificating on criminal justice theory -- he
was robbed, and as a witness, he messed it all up.
It went like this: He testified under oath that
burglars entered his house through a window. They
actually came in through the cellar. He said they
left a clock packed in paper. It was wrapped in a
tablecloth. He gave a complete list of garments
that were stolen; it turns out they took 7 more
than he said. He claimed he found candle wax on
the 2nd floor… but the wax drippings were actually
in the attic. Finally, he reported 2 burglars.
But maybe it was just 1 -- he had no way to tell.
Münsterberg had given over 3,000 academic lectures
and not once had to use note cards. His mind and
memory were amazing. But he admitted that he’d
rushed into the house and surveyed it all quickly,
noting after the fact that his brain filled in
the gaps for him. The burglar was eventually
caught breaking into another house, and they
found Münsterberg’s jacket in his apartment.
But the fact is -- the world’s expert on witness
reliability -- was almost completely wrong. He
said, “I felt myself somewhat alarmed in
seeing how many illusions had come in.”
So…
If the pioneer of witness reliability
scholarship couldn't overcome his
illusions, what chance did a college student
traumatized by a violent sexual assault have?
Police presented Jennifer Thompson with a photo
lineup of 6 men. They told her that the suspect
might not even be in the lineup -- but she
figured if he wasn’t there, why would they
bother? She recognized one of the photos and
chose Ronald Cotton with absolute certainty.
A week later, Jennifer recognized the
same man in a physical lineup. To her,
the parts that didn’t match her memory made
him even guiltier -- like he’d changed his
hair to purposely deceive her. The photo lineup
reinforced her mental image of her attacker,
and anti-proof became proof. Police
confirmed that she’d chosen the same
man in both lineups. She said, "It was
him. There was no doubt in my mind."
Did you feel absolutely certain?
Absolutely certain. Well, what was
said to me afterwards was, “That’s the same
person you picked out in the photo lineup.”
So in my mind I thought, “Bingo! I did it right!”
So if that’s the case… How can
the truth compete with that?
“Estimator variables” are the parts of eyewitness
identification that police can’t control. So like,
cross-racial ID’s tend to be less accurate
than ID’s within a witness’s race. That isn’t
the police’s fault. People think different
things, and they just plain see different
things -- from an optical illusion to the colors
of a dress. But the real enemy of memory is time.
Hermann Ebbinghaus’s forgetting curve
provides a visual representation of how
quickly your memory can erode -- and
as early as the 1880’s his equation
expressed the vulnerability of memory
over time. But forgetting over time is
only half the problem -- the other
half is teaching yourself the lie.
Every time you re-tell your story to police,
to a lawyer, to a journalist, to a friend,
you’re essentially engaging in the spaced
repetition of practice. You’re learning. Your
memories get clearer, almost like memorizing
lines for a play. So the longer it’s been,
the more you forget. The more you forget,
the more you invent. The more you repeat,
the more confident you are
-- whether it’s true or not.
Jennifer Thompson said, “If
there was a death penalty,
I wanted Ronald Cotton to get it. I would pull
the switch if they let me.” When she pointed
her finger at Cotton to identify him during
the trial, she said she wished it had been
a gun. Ronald Cotton had become her attacker
in her mind through unconscious transference.
But there was no physical evidence -- no
fingerprints, no clothing, no fibers from
the victim’s apartment -- linking Ronald Cotton
to the crime. He maintained his innocence and
refused to entertain a plea bargain. He was
convicted based largely on Jennifer’s testimony.
3 years later, Jennifer Thompson came face to face
with her actual attacker
-- and didn’t even notice.
Ronald Cotton was given a new trial -- that’s
great, right? WRONG -- this time he also faced
charges for another assault and burglary from
that same night. Meanwhile, he’d met a man in
prison who looked a lot like Jennifer’s original
composite sketch -- and he looked so similar to
Ronald Cotton that other inmates couldn’t tell
them apart. Bobby Poole lived in the same town as
Ronald and Jennifer, and he was currently serving
a sentence for sexual assault. If all of that
wasn’t enough to raise suspicions, he’d literally
confessed to other inmates that he assaulted her.
Ronald’s lawyers called Bobby Poole as
a witness in the new trial. Poole denied
everything. Jennifer Thompson had wanted to be
the one to personally execute Ronald Cotton,
but when she was in the same courtroom as her
real attacker, the man whose face she’d studied,
she didn’t recognize him at all. Ronald was
convicted again and sent back to prison.
Richard Rosen, a professor at UNC-Chapel
Hill, and lawyer Tom Lambeth took on Ronald’s
case. They secured the DNA analysis that
wasn’t available in 1984. Ronald insisted
that he'd be cleared -- and the stakes were
high. A DNA match would cement his guilt.
Ronald wasn’t lying. The tests showed that not
only was Ronald innocent, but that Bobby Poole
was the attacker -- and over 10 years after
first being arrested, Ronald Cotton was free.
Jennifer didn’t dispute the DNA findings. She
knew she’d been proven wrong. She wasn’t defensive
about it; she was horrified. She said, “I had
to tell people not only was I was a rape victim,
but a rape victim with an extremely bad memory
and someone had to pay 11 years for that.
I wondered how I could have been so stupid.”
Jennifer was not stupid. During the attack she
actually convinced Poole to get rid of his knife,
then outwitted him by offering to get him a
drink and using the distraction to escape.
She just fell prey to the vulnerabilities
all witnesses have and a few simple changes
can drastically improve witness reliability.
Lineups that offer a range of similar choices
are most effective -- that way suspects can’t
stand out. And making lineups sequential, so
one photo at a time is compared to a witness’s
memory instead of being compared to one another,
is even more effective. Police need to make it
clear to witnesses that the suspect might not
be there -- and the cops who make the lineup
shouldn’t be the ones who administer it.
That ‘double blind’ process ensures police
can’t give any verbal or non-verbal cues
to the witness to influence their choice.
Recording the lineup solidifies the record,
and police should ask witnesses to detail
their level of confidence in their choice.
But Jennifer Thompson would’ve said 100%,
and advancing science was the only thing that
saved Ronald Cotton from a life in prison.
“In my mind, I was sure of what I saw.
Um. Thinking back on it, uh, I don’t know
that I would’ve done anything different.”
Jennifer and Ronald are friends
now. He never blamed her for being
wrong. They’ve given talks together nationwide,
their families are close, and they even end
phone conversations by saying “Love you.”
Half the states in the US have instituted some
form of eyewitness identification reform. But
can we make sure what happened to both Ronald
Cotton and Jennifer Thompson never happens again?
Probably not. Hugo Münsterberg was right --
from biological limitations to systematic error,
the moment our eyes and ears capture
something, the truth is vulnerable.
We can get better, but we'll never be perfect.
2,200 years ago, the Roman playwright Plautus said
that “1 eyewitness is worth 10 ear witnesses.”
People attest to the truth by saying
they saw something with their own two
eyes. They’ll tell you that something is
so good you need to see it to believe it.
But the truth is… sometimes you
need to believe it to see it.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Vsauce! Kevin here -- with the dumbest
math ever used to convict an innocent
person in a court of law. It all started
with a little old lady in an alleyway,
and it ended by defining how we use
probabilistic evidence in trials, with
the California Supreme court warning that bad math
could become a “veritable sorcerer” to ruin law.
Almost 60 years ago, a petty neighborhood
robbery you've never heard of changed everything.
An elderly woman named Juanita Brooks was walking
down an alleyway when someone shoved
her to the ground. She looked up to
see a blonde woman running away -- and
that woman had taken Juanita’s purse.
At the end of the alley, a man named John Bass
witnessed a white blonde woman with a ponytail
get into a yellow car and drive past him. He saw
that the driver was a black man with a beard and
a mustache. These SOUND LIKE the basic facts of
the case -- but they ended up becoming numbers.
And it happened because of total uncertainty.
John Bass saw that the woman had a ponytail;
Juanita Brooks couldn’t remember if she
did. A police officer asked around local
gas stations until he found someone who
said that an interracial couple filled
up their yellow car there frequently --
Janet Collins and her husband Malcolm.
They’d only been married for 2 weeks, and
now they were being arrested for robbery.
When Juanita Brooks and John Bass were asked
to identify Janet and Malcolm from photos,
neither one could do it. Juanita completely
blanked, and Bass only saw a resemblance in
the ponytail. The police still had some
case -- their alibi was a little shaky,
Malcolm had a criminal record, and a recorded
conversation with police showed Janet’s desire
to take the blame to protect her husband.
And that’s when desperation kicked in.
The prosecution turned Juanita Brooks’
assault and theft into a probability problem.
Prosecutor Ray Sinetar brought in a professor
from Cal State Long Beach to help him prove
to the jury mathematically that Janet and
Malcolm Collins were guilty. The professor
testified to the validity of the product rule
-- which is that if events are independent,
you can multiply the probabilities of each to
find the chance that they happen together. For
example, if Thing A has a 1 in 5 chance of
happening, and Thing B has a 1 in 10 chance
of happening, then both of them happening
separately-but-together is 1 in 50, or 2%.
So what did Sinetar do next? He
started literally making up numbers.
Sinetar invented 6 vague estimates
touching on the only details that
John Bass and Juanita Brooks could provide.
Here’s what he said. He said the chances of:
-- A black man having a beard were 1 out of 10.
-- That a man would have a mustache? 1 out of 4.
-- That a white woman had blonde hair: 1 out of 3.
-- That a woman had a ponytail:
1 out of 10.
-- That an
interracial couple would be in a car: 1 in 1,000.
-- And that the car would be yellow? 1 in 10.
Sure. The professor was given a
pencil and paper to work out the
probability of all those 6 events happening
together using the product rule, and he did:
the answer was 1 in 12,000,000. And that
was it. He left the witness stand. Yeah.
If you watched my video about Sally Clark,
you know exactly what’s happening here.
The prosecutor explained to the jury
that this sort of mathematical proof
was actually better than the concept
of proof beyond a reasonable doubt,
because it dealt with hard numbers instead of
vague beliefs. He called it the “new math,” and
he said it would help convict the people
who “push old ladies down and take their
money. “ He said that Malcolm and Janet Collins
were the only two people in Los Angeles who could
satisfy all the elements of probability in
this case. He suggested that they had to be
the 1 in 12 million -- because with all those
pieces matching up, how could they NOT be?
But this wasn’t new math. It was bad math. And
it was still enough to convict the Collinses
of second degree robbery. And
in Jim Crow-era Los Angeles,
there was almost certainly an
element of racial bias supporting it.
Malcolm Collins appealed his conviction, and
it went to California's Supreme Court -- and
they finally obliterated
the prosecutor’s stupidity.
The math was obviously wrong -- starting
with the completely made-up odds for each
characteristic. It’s not like the
prosecutor analyzed the vehicle
registrations of all California automobiles
to determine that 10% of the state’s cars
were yellow. He didn’t conduct a massive
survey of hairdressers to find out what
percentage of their clients pulled their
hair back into a pontail. He just guessed.
Then he failed to acknowledge that these
events are NOT independent -- like beards
and mustaches. Ya know, they kinda tend
to come as a pair… a lot. Not always,
but a lot. So, you can’t just straight
up multiply them like they’re coin flips.
But here’s the big one. Let’s say the math
is accurate -- which it isn’t. You’ve found
a couple who satisfy all the conditions to be
the 1 in 12 million. Great. How do you know
THEY are the couple who committed the crime?!
Are they the only two people in the greater
Los Angeles metropolitan area who were a blonde
ponytail and black mustached-and-bearded couple
in a yellow car?? Surely there weren’t MANY
-- but there’s a decent chance there’s a few.
The Supreme Court actually calculated
the probability that another couple
fitting the same exact description at over
40%. 40%! So even if the math checked out,
there’s pretty close to even odds that
Janet and Malcolm were the wrong couple.
3 years later, Malcolm’s conviction was
overturned and he was released -- Janet
had been given a short sentence, and
she’d already served it. The Collinses
never really got justice. Janet served
her time and Malcolm lost a few years
of his life -- but the biggest loser was
the validity of probabilistic evidence.
It’s the most glaring example of the
prosecutor’s fallacy -- and it’s taken
decades to undo the damage Ray Sinetar
caused to the use of math in the courtroom.
But the fallout wasn’t ALL bad. It did lead
to the “Collins test,” a set of conditions
the introduction of probability needs to satisfy
for the math to be relevant and valid in a trial:
1) The probability factors need to be
accurate -- you can’t just make them up;
2) The calculations are done correctly and
formulas are applied appropriately -- like…
not abusing the product rule
to get the result you want;
3) All the factors being calculated
actually apply to the parties involved,
4) And the evidence proves there
could be only ONE result -- so,
that the Collinses could be the ONLY possible
couple capable of satisfying every condition.
The police never did figure out who knocked
Juanita Brooks down and stole her purse. In 1965,
two criminals in Los Angeles got $40 richer, and
math got a lot less trustworthy in the courtroom.
But without it we don’t have the Collins
test, or an ever-evolving debate about how
we can leverage what we know about math to find
out what we don’t know about everything else.
Proving that sometimes things have to get really
dumb before we can even start to get… smart.
And as always - thanks for watching.
Vsauce!
Kevin here -- Kevin Lieber, actually.
That’s my name, it’s German.
But I’m not the only one -- there are 10
other Kevin Liebers in the United States.
So… what if one of the other Kevin Liebers
is connected to a murder… of another YouTuber…
3 miles from right here.
And the only surviving victim identified ME,
Kevin Lieber, as the killer?
To top it all off, Mr Beast testified that
I confessed to him?
And only one who knows I’m innocent!?
All of this really happened.
Not to me -- to a woman named Joyce Ann Brown.
They need a conviction.
They needed the pressure off.
Two blacks in Dallas, Texas?
In Texas period?
Walked in broad open daylight… show and
killed a business man?
Somebody was gonna pay.
I’m that somebody.
On Thursday, May 8th, 1980, the Dallas Morning
News published a short article buried in the
paper’s Local News section -- a shop called
Fine Furs by Rubin had been robbed and its
owner, Rubin Danziger, was murdered.
His wife Ala said Rubin pleaded, “Don’t
hurt me, don’t hurt me,” before one of
two female robbers shot him in the head.
Ala escaped by telling them she had terminal
cancer with just weeks to live.
One of the women said, “We’ll just let
you suffer,” and left.
As police looked for suspects, they found
the getaway car -- a Datsun rented to a woman
named Joyce Ann Brown.
A police officer recognized the name as someone
who’d been arrested years prior for a minor
sex work charge, so they asked publicly for
Joyce Ann Brown to come in for questioning.
Joyce immediately went into the police station
to clear up the confusion.
She wasn’t worried -- she knew she didn’t
do it and she had an alibi.
She was at work when the crime occurred.
And this is where the incredible coincidences
really begin.
Joyce worked at Koslow’s, another fur store
just across town, so she’d presumably know
which valuable furs to steal.
Working nearby in the fur industry with the
same first, middle and last name as the getaway
car’s renter?
Quite a coincidence.
But.
Even so, Joyce denied any involvement.
The interrogator told her, ​​“You’re
lying, we know you pulled that robbery.”
She was arrested and held on $1 million bail.
Then police realized that the Joyce Ann Brown
who rented the car actually lived in Denver,
Colorado -- she was a completely different
person in a completely different state -- and
THAT Joyce said that she’d lent the car
to a friend -- but by then it was too late.
Joyce’s mugshot from her prior arrest had
been shown in a lineup to Mrs. Danziger, who
identified her as one of the robbers and she
said that that woman had been in the store
to case it out in the weeks leading up to
the crime.
Forget a weird name thing.
Now the police had an eyewitness identification.
Okay but what about Joyce’s solid work alibi?
There was about a 7-minute window that would’ve
allowed Joyce to commit the robbery, leave
the scene, change her clothes, drive back
to work, and compose herself as if nothing
was out of the ordinary before talking to
a co-worker at 1:19pm -- and the police said
that must be exactly what happened.
But what ACTUALLY happened?
None of the items recovered from police searches
-- the rental car, Joyce’s apartment -- linked
her to the crime.
But when evidence starts to suggest that weird
things are coincidences, it’s tempting to…
just come up with new evidence.
Suddenly a woman named Martha Jean Bruce claimed
that Joyce had confessed to her while they
shared a jail cell after Joyce’s arrest.
Bruce said there was no incentive for her
to testify to that, but remarkably a few months
later the DA recommended that Bruce be released
over 3 years early on a 5-year attempted murder
sentence.
So yeah.
The DA’s investigator Adi Christian found
her story convincing.
Well, after I talked to her a little bit in
detail she began to tell me some things that
indicated to me that she would’ve had to
have talked to someone involved in that crime
because of the facts she had.
About the way the furs were supposedly baggaged
when they left the scene.
And Martha Jean Bruce had that information,
she knew that they were in plastic bags.
But she could’ve read that in the newspapers.
Oh, and Martha Jean Bruce had already been
convicted of lying to police.
But the prosecutors ignored that.
The odds of it all being the universe’s
cruel joke against Joyce Ann Brown were just...
too much for the jury.
She was found guilty and sentenced -- and
there was no hope the calculus was ever gonna
be in her favor.
Everything added up for the prosecution, and
the pattern checked out.
Their case went like this: Joyce Ann Brown
is the black former prostitute in Texas accused
of involvement in the robbery and murder of
a holocaust survivor on her lunch break from
work at the same type of store a few miles
away, with the surviving
victim visually identifying
her, sworn testimony of a jailhouse confession,
and the getaway car rented in her exact name.
Here’s a question.
What are the odds someone with YOUR name commits
a crime?
Since there are only 10 other Kevin Liebers,
I’m pretty safe.
But what if your name is…
Michael Stevens?
There are 2,975 total Michael Stevenses in
the United States.
How about John Smith?
He’s got 48,439 other potential criminal
John Smiths.
Conversely, Tanner Butt’s innocence is firmly
up to him.
6 months after Joyce’s conviction, the other
woman linked to the robbery and murder was
finally apprehended.
Rene Taylor.
Police found furs and the murder weapon in
her apartment.
She told police that she had no idea who Joyce
Ann Brown was… but she refused to give up
the name of her actual accomplice because
she didn’t want to ruin that woman’s life.
Rene Taylor was convicted of murder and sent
to the Mountain View maximum security prison,
where she served time with…
Joyce Ann Brown.
Guards were ordered to keep the two women
apart.
Joyce is in prison.
Rene Taylor is in prison.
But It took years to determine who Rene’s
real accomplice was -- a woman named Lorraine
Germany who’d also robbed an Albuquerque,
New Mexico fur store with Taylor -- and an
investigator told Joyce that “Lorraine looked
enough like you to be your twin sister.”
Name.
Furs.
DOPPELGANGER.
Ridiculous.
In 1984, Joyce’s appeal was denied on her
birthday.
2 weeks later, her son shot himself.
His last words to her were, “Mama, when
are they going to let you out?
We don’t have a family anymore.”
Most crimes aren’t all THAT different from
each other, and the details usually add up.
There are often familiar patterns.
The Dallas police fell victim to the Einstellung
Effect, a cognitive phenomenon detailed in
my video "Can Learning Make You Dumb?"
They had tunnel vision based on their experience.
They also had a lot of possible evidence to
choose from, so they only saw what they wanted
to see -- and they wanted to see it in a certain
way.
It’s the same mistake we saw with Brandon
Mayfield’s fingerprint case.
And just like Sally Clark’s trial, the prosecution
and jury refused to admit that long odds and
crazy coincidences really do happen -- they
just do.
Or maybe they just didn’t understand that
they do.
One way to combat the Einstellung Effect is
to bring in people to look at the problem
who aren’t used to operating in familiar
patterns.
Dallas Morning News journalists Steve McGonigal
and Steve Blow started questioning the district
attorney’s narrative.
Jim McCloskey of Centurion
Ministries in Princeton,
New Jersey and his own investigator started
putting the evidence together to get Joyce
exonerated.
And in 1989, just weeks after Morley Safer
of 60 Minutes aired a 14-minute piece detailing
the doubt surrounding Joyce’s conviction,
she was finally granted a retrial.
For the first time in 9 years, 5 months, and
24 days, Joyce was free -- and months later,
the DA dropped the case against her.
Joyce Ann Brown spent the years following
her release working as an assistant to a county
official before founding an organization to
assist the incarcerated and their families.
She died of a heart attack in 2015.
Joyce’s strength and character allowed her
to turn her injustice into a springboard to
help other people.
But… she never should’ve had to in the
first place.
Joyce wrote in her book “Justice Denied”
that she, “... had faith in the system.
If you did a crime, you did the time.
If you were innocent, you went free.”
The thing is -- lives like Joyce Ann Brown’s
have been and will continue to be destroyed
because we keep getting the same things wrong.
We fall prey to the same cognitive biases,
analytical fallacies, and just plain thinking
errors that I’ve been exploring on this
channel for years.
One day it’s the Einstellung effect -- the
next day it’s confirmation bias, or any
of dozens of misinterpretations in math.
I know all of these things.
YOU know all of these things.
But not everyone else does
-- and their compounding
errors can determine the freedom of people
named… well, whatever your first, middle,
and last name is.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Well the first thing I'm gonna do is spend
some time with my daughter.
And that very night I'm gonna sleep in the
bed with my momma.
I've been waitin' on that day a long time.
Vsauce! Kevin here -- with a math crime
so sinister the Michigan Supreme Court
stated that no other game operated
more extensively or demoralized so
many people. City police forces repeatedly
shut it down, and the FBI waged all-out
war against it. And it made criminals out of
people like… a Detroit mom named Miss Fannie.
What they didn’t know is that
they were fighting against a
nearly perfect game that was about
way more than just beating the odds.
In Atlanta, it was called “Playing The Bug”
-- in Harlem and elsewhere, it was still
called “Policy” after the original game that drew
numbers from 1 to 78. But the real name is just
“Numbers” -- and although it was associated with
black communities, everyone played the Numbers.
When Fannie Davis set up her Detroit
neighborhood Numbers game in 1958,
there just wasn’t much economic opportunity
for the black community -- so, she started
her own business. And she funded it
after winning big on Numbers herself.
It worked like this.
You’d place a bet on a 3-digit number from
000 to 999, and that could hit one of two
ways. You could play it straight, where
you hoped to hit the exact number -- like,
607 -- and you’d be paid 500 or 600 times
your bet. Or you could bet a number “boxed,”
meaning you’d win if any combination of your
numbers hit. That’s 3!, so 3 x 2 x 1 = 6
possible combinations [607, 670, 760, 706,
067, 076], and it would pay about 80 to 1.
Okay. So. How did they choose the winning number?
I’ve got a cage full of balls numbered 1 to 100 --
I’ll give it a crank and then I’ll draw three. I’m
gonna play: 394. That’s my lucky number because
.394 was Tony Gwynn’s batting average in 1994
when he was on pace to hit over .400 for the
first time since Ted Williams hit .406 in 1941,
but a labor strike shortened the baseball
season and RUINED EVERYTHING. Okay. Here we go…
32. I already lost. Oh well let’s keep going.
Oh.
My cage of balls broke. Oh. I am
a fool. Oh there’s so many on the
floor. Alright let’s finish this
off. Stay closed. 86. Last number.
91. The winning number was 261, my number is 394.
Sorry, Tony...
But… this method is silly. No
one would trust a guy pulling
balls out of a cage in his house. To
get the winning number in a more fair
manner… I could do something like… take
3 YouTube videos, reload them each day
on a livestream and use the ones digit from
the view counts to pick the winning number.
And Fannie’s game worked kinda similar to that.
She used the “mutuel” from a local racetrack
-- the betting totals for win, place,
and show on a series of horse races. She’d
take the ones digit from the 4th, 5th, and 6th
race totals, and there’s your 3 numbers. It was
technically possible to influence those digits,
but incredibly difficult -- and expensive. Other
games used independent numbers like digits from
the published daily balance of the US Treasury
-- things you could open up a newspaper and see.
Look, here’s the real beauty of Numbers and why
it worked so well for Fannie and her community:
You win just often enough to enjoy playing,
and to validate every possible betting
system. If you play 6 days a week you’ll
probably win boxed 2 or 3 times a year,
and you’ll hit straight for 500 times your
bet every few years. Did a number come to
you in a dream? Do you think you have a scientific
lottery-beating system? They all end up winning.
And yeah, the house edge was steep -- getting
paid 500 to 1 on something you know has a 1 in
1,000 chance of happening means someone’s making
money somewhere. They’re also taking bets,
keeping meticulous records,
collecting money from losses
and distributing money from wins -- all as
they’re calculating their own mathematical
risk of ruin in real-time to make sure they
can survive financially if someone hits big.
But for Fannie’s neighbors, they could
see $1 become $500 overnight. The FBI saw
an opportunity to rip it away from
them and give it to… someone else.
Law enforcement called the Numbers game
racketeering, and in 1970 the FBI led
what J Edgar Hoover called the largest
gambling raid in history, shutting down
58 Numbers operators. Then governments
realized that if the house always wins,
they could just… become the house. States made
Numbers illegal, did their best to wipe it out,
and then gave themselves a legal Numbers
monopoly. Wow! What a neat trick!
Lotteries have actually had a really complex
history in the United States -- from the colonial
period to early statehood, hundreds of lotteries
helped raise money for schools and public works.
By the 1830’s, lotteries were denounced by social
reformers as morally bankrupt, predatory games
that generated “tainted revenue” -- and in 1895
lottery games were banned nationwide. From legal
lotteries to policy houses, there was enough
corruption and game-fixing to consider what was
best for the public interest. Now 44 states have
legalized lotteries, and the Powerball is played
in all of them -- to help raise money for schools
and public works. And we’ve come full circle.
But the reality is to run a game like Numbers,
what you really need is the
trust of your community.
Fannie Davis and other boutique Numbers
operators engaged in a sort of prescient
scholarship decades before neuroscience
and psychology research confirmed what they
harnessed intuitively -- the community
element of Numbers was everything.
They seized the power of Dunbar’s
Number, building on the social
cohesion in well-connected neighborhoods so
everyone could play a game together — and
that’s completely lost when 100,000 strangers
play a lottery anonymously at a gas station.
They knew that throwing in just one additional
number meant only hitting straight once every
30 years -- that’s probably once in a
lifetime. And that’s not often enough
for most people to wanna keep playing, even
if it increases the prizes dramatically.
They intuited the communal strength
of Rene Girard’s mimetic desire,
and how much people love playing
games together -- and need to.
And they actually knew how to make a small economy
work: Numbers created tens of thousands of jobs
within communities trying to survive in the face
of discrimination, segregation and rampant racism.
A 1903 Detroit Free Press article said Numbers
was “largely the gambling field of the ignorant,
superstitious, and poor… the
main thing is to have the evil
eternally wiped out.” Lottery ban legislation
was a patronizing attempt to protect communities
from themselves. Now we’ve got Japan’s
Takarakuji, South Korea’s Lotto 6/45,
the US Mega Millions and Russia’s Gosloto -- in
addition to US state games that operate exactly
like Numbers did decades ago. Pennsylvania even
named their 3-digit lottery “The Daily Number.”
But those games can’t do what people like Fannie
Davis did in Detroit. There’s no talk at the diner
about who won that week or who hasn’t hit in
ages. There’s no knock on the door to deliver
your lucky payout the day after your numbers
match. There’s no playing 357 because you live
at 357 Park Drive and everyone knowing when that
number hit – YOU were the winner. That’s all gone.
There’s enough intrigue about Fannie Davis’s
life and her Numbers game to fill a great
docuseries -- and there were thousands like her.
Read Bridgett Davis’s book about her mom -- that’s
her story to tell, not mine. Check out Felicia
George’s dissertation about Numbers in Detroit,
or Louise Meriwether’s novel “Daddy
was a Number Runner” -- you’ve heard
a million stories about the good guys
and bad guys during Prohibition. But
Numbers stories like Miss Fannie’s
have been almost entirely ignored.
But they shouldn’t be.
Because alongside the rackets were people who
understood the social fabric of their communities.
Making your own way in the world and
making everyone else a little bit
happier? That’s not the American
Dream, that’s everyone’s dream.
But the highly-regulated mass-production of fun
strips the complex social function from a game
that’s the perfect blend of math and people.
It’s reduced to lonely, anonymous gambling.
And when that happens, the only
thing left is just… numbers.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Vsauce! Kevin here. And I’m about to bust the
greatest female tycoon of the 19th century
using FORENSIC MATH -- I just need skim milk, an
amputated leg, and a family of nerds to do it.
Millions of dollars were at stake --
and it all came down to handwriting.
I’ve told some stories about how
math has perverted the pursuit
of justice and destroyed lives --
but when one of America’s richest
women tried to steal even more
money, math detected her fraud.
Hetty Green was bred to make money -- and
she was the best at it. At 6 years old,
Hetty was reading financial newspapers
to her father, who owned a whaling firm
in Massachusetts. She tracked stock prices
with her grandfather, and by age 13 was the
family bookkeeper. In the 1850’s, the family
had MILLIONS -- which in today’s money is TENS
of millions. But Hetty needed more. And
when her aunt died, she saw dollar signs.
First, you need to understand Hetty. Her
entire LIFE was all about money -- and
she racked up a fortune that would be
valued well into the BILLIONS today.
She was known as the “Witch of Wall Street”
-- but she was famously miserly. She was
just as obsessed with making money as
she was with never spending ANY of it.
Here are some examples.
She spent so long trying to find a free clinic
to treat her son’s leg injury that she waited
too long and it had to be amputated. She refused
to use hot water because fuel to heat it felt like
a waste of money. She wore one black dress and a
single set of underwear that she only changed when
they wore out. When she bailed out the New York
City government by writing a check to cover its
budgetary shortfalls, she was living in boarding
houses -- because she wanted to. She said, “Just
because I dress plainly and do not spend a fortune
on my gowns, they say I am cranky or insane.”
Hetty Green wasn’t insane -- but she was a
criminal. And that’s where the math comes in.
When her aunt Sylvia died in 1865, her
will stipulated that about $1 million
would go to charities. That’s about $15
million today. The other $1 million would
be put in a trust for Hetty. So
half for charity. Half for Hetty.
Here’s what happened next...
Hetty remarkably produced an earlier copy
of the will stating that 100% of her aunt’s
fortune would go directly to her… which
seemed pretty convenient. It also had a
page attached that invalidated any future
wills, which seemed… really convenient.
The estate’s executor, Thomas Mandell,
saw it and was like, “I don’t think so.”
So what did Hetty do? She sued the estate
-- and that’s when nerds came to the rescue.
Charles Sanders Peirce was a literal genius
-- by age 23, he had 3 degrees from Harvard.
He eventually became one of America’s greatest
logicians, including realizing in 1886 that
electrical circuits could carry out logical
operations. That resulted in the digital computer
decades later, but in 1865, he entered a courtroom
in Boston to analyze Aunt Sylvia’s handwriting.
Charles compared 42 samples of Sylvia’s
signature and concluded that it had 30
downstrokes -- in graphonomics, a “ballistic
stroke” that conveys a distinct change in the
absolute velocity of the pen. My signature
has 18 -- 8 in Kevin, 10 in Lieber.
Here’s a question. How consistent is a
signature? How much did Sylvia’s vary
from sample to sample? How much does MINE vary?
I signed my name, and then I made 42 more
signatures -- and tried to make them match. Then I
judged each sample against the original signature
to find out how many of the 18 downstrokes in my
name were the same -- I looked at size, length,
and angle to determine whether each stroke was
substantially similar. They followed a normal
distribution, and the result was an average
of 7.405 matches out of a possible 18 -- so
only 41% the same. And I was really trying to
make them the same! Sylvia’s 42 signatures
were probably done over a period of years.
But the interesting thing is the variance -- my
signatures have a standard deviation of 1.326,
which means that 99.73% of my
signatures should fall between
3.427 and 11.383 -- that’s a range of plus
and minus 3 sigma. The Z-score of each
sample indicates how many standard deviations
that sample is from the mean -- basically,
how much of an outlier it is. My most deviant
sample was 10 matches, for a Z-score of 1.957.
I actually did one more set of
comparisons just to make sure.
I compared signature #21 to all the
others. The mean was 6.810 matches and
the standard deviation was 1.418. The
highest Z score was still only 2.249.
Based on my 42 samples, how deviant would
a perfect 18-for-18 match actually be? It
would have a Z-score of 7.989 -- nearly 8
standard deviations from the mean. The odds
of a signature being seven standard
deviations from the mean are about 1
in 390 billion -- the odds of 7.989? Uhhh.
Figure it out and tell me in the comments.
Back to Hetty.
Charles Peirce found that Sylvia’s 42
samples had an average of 6 downward
strokes matching the will’s signature
-- so about 20% -- and conformed to
a binomial distribution just
like mine. And probably YOURS.
When Charles compared the signature on the
first page of the will to the signature on
the attached second page, he found that
all 30 downstrokes were a perfect match.
A 100% perfect match. His father Benjamin
Peirce was a Harvard mathematician -- he
testified that the probability of Sylvia’s
second signature being a perfect 30 for 30
match was 2.666 x 10^21 -- or 1 in 2
sextillion, 666 quintillion. So yeah.
Benjamin Peirce said, “Such evanescent
shadows of probability cannot belong to
actual life.” Which is an amazing quote. Uhhh
yeah, Hetty traced Aunt Sylvia’s signature.
She lost the case and fled with her husband
to London when the family threatened to have
her indicted for fraud. But… she didn’t
really lose. After 5 years in court,
she was awarded $600,000 from the estate -- less
than the original legitimate will gave her, but
still $12 million in today’s money. And the state
never brought criminal charges against... the
wealthiest woman living in it. The following year,
Hetty had a daughter -- who she named Sylvia.
Hetty Green died during a heated argument with her
maid about the benefits of skim milk. Today her
estate would be valued at $5 billion. She really
was America’s first female business tycoon -- and
she wasn’t all bad. She became an anonymous
philanthropist and served as a nurse to care for
friends and family. In 1951, Sylvia Green died,
leaving over 99% of the family fortune to charity.
I’ve made videos about the crazy odds of two
people having the same name -- and having weirdly
similar fingerprints -- and having rare tragedies
strike twice in the same family. I’ve shown that
math alone is a terrible basis for convicting
someone of a crime -- and insane odds can still
mean innocence. With Sylvia Ann Howland’s
will, we have to consider the totality of
the circumstances: Hetty’s motive, her obsessive
greed, her miraculous production of a will that
just happened to be entirely in her favor -- all
combined with truly astronomical signature odds.
Knowing when not to believe in
coincidences is just as crucial as
accepting them. 1 in a billion? Okay --
if 1 in a billion people won a lottery,
that means about 8 people alive right
now would hit the jackpot. It’s not
impossible. A mountain of evidence plus 1 in
2.6 sextillion? Yeah. I don’t think so, Hetty.
Hetty Green spent a lifetime accumulating money,
power, and influence -- and she could never
get enough of any of it. But in the end,
all of Hetty’s precious millions couldn’t
compete with the Peirce family’s sextillions.
And as always, thanks for watching.
So there’s an important point about
why I chose these stories. They’re
statistical outliers. They’re the
extremes. Most cases don’t need
multi-year analysis of expected health
outcomes or poring over 30 downstrokes
of 42 different signatures. These stories
are interesting because they’re unusual.
But anomalies and aberrations often
lay bare the problems we have with
the mundane. Brandon Mayfield’s case
happened after 100 years of forensic
fingerprint analysis -- that’s a
full century of misunderstandings.
The truth is that highlighting the
extremes is often the most compelling
and illuminating way to understand
how generally fragile our grip is on
concepts like basic probability
or identifying your attacker.
We’ve spent thousands of years trying
to understand and refine justice --
and we’re just getting started.
And as always, thanks for watching.